bonjour à tous aujourd'hui à l'occasion
de la sortie du film qui lui est
consacré je voudrais vous parler de
stephen hawking et de ses travaux de
recherches sur la théorie du tout vous
êtes peut-être vu qu'en france est sorti
il ya quelques jours ce film qui
s'appelle une merveilleuse histoire du
temps et c'est un film qui retrace la
vie du célèbre astrophysicien stephen
hawking vous savez peut-être que ce à
quoi stephen hawking a consacré une
bonne partie de sa vie de chercheur
c'est la recherche de ce qu'on appelle
la théorie du tout d'ailleurs c'est le
titre en anglais du film s'appelle the
theory of everything
alors aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
expliquer qu'est ce que c'est la théorie
du tout pourquoi on l'appelle comme ça
pourquoi on la cherche
et puis qu'est-ce qu'elle fait aux kings
alors pour comprendre ce que c'est que
la théorie du tout il faut remonter à la
première moitié du 20e siècle
vous savez peut-être que à cette époque
ont lieu deux très grandes révolutions
en physique fondamentale la première ça
a été la découverte de la théorie de la
relativité générale par einstein la
théorie de la relativité générale c'est
une théorie de la force de gravité alors
en fait à l'époque ou einstein propose
sa théorie on avait déjà une théorie de
la force de gravité c'était la théorie
de newton la loi de l'attraction
universelle celle qu'on apprend en
physique au lycée et einstein est parti
d'un principe différent il a proposé que
si les corps massif satire c'est pas
parce qu'il existe une force entre eux
mais c'est parce qu'il courbe
l'espace-temps alors la théorie
d'einstein en fait elle apporte pas
énormément de choses nouvelles par
rapport à celle de newton
sauf quand les objets sont très lourds
il ya notamment deux cas très
particulier le premier c'est l'existence
des trous noirs
la théorie d'einstein nous dit il existe
des régions de l'espace dont rien ne
peut s'échapper
même pas la lumière c'est ce qu'on
appelle les trous noirs et aujourd'hui
on sait que les trous noirs existent par
exemple y en a un qui est tranquillement
assis en plein milieu de notre galaxie
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez regarder dans
sa direction si en été vous visez la
constellation du sagittaire
l'autre grande nouveauté qui a été
apportée par la théorie d'einstein c'est
l'idée de l'expansion de l'univers
la théorie d'einstein me dis que
l'univers est en expansion et que si on
remonte le temps qu'on remonte le film
de l'histoire de l'univers il ya 13,7
milliards d'années il était dans un état
complètement contracté sur lui-même très
dense très chaud et c'est ça qu'on
appelle le big
donc le big bang c'est qu'une
conséquence de la relativité générale
l'autre grande révolution qu'a eu lieu à
peu près la même période en parallèle
c'est la mécanique quantique la
mécanique quantique c'est un petit peu
l'opposé de la relativité générale
puisque c'est une théorie de la matière
au niveau microscopique ans par
microscopie
qu'est ce qu'on entend on entend les
atomes et puis tout ce qui est en
dessous tout quatre plus petits les
protons les électrons toutes les
particules fondamentales et la mécanique
quantique
elle nous décrit un monde qui au niveau
microscopique est assez différent du
monde dont on a l'habitude au niveau
macroscopique le mieux pour comprendre
ça c'est de penser à un atom
vous savez on représente souvent un atom
comme une sorte de système planétaire
des électrons qui tourne autour des
protons un peu de la même manière que
des planètes peuvent tourner autour
d'une étoile
en fait la mécanique quantique nous dit
que les choses se passent d'une manière
assez différente pour les planètes qui
tournent autour d'une étoile elle se
trouve en général à une distance donnée
de l'étoile mais elles pourraient se
trouver à priori à n'importe quel autre
distance n'y a pas de distance imposée
au niveau microscopique pour les
électrons il ya des orbites imposé c'est
à dire qu'un électron il peut se trouver
qu'à une certaine distance du proton il
peut se trouver sur une orbite il peut
se trouver sur la suivante mais il peut
pas se trouver entre les deux les
chaussons discontinues on dit parfois
qu'elles sont quantifiées d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui donne son nom à la
mécanique quantique
l'autre grande nouveauté au niveau
microscopique c'est que les particules
peuvent être dans plusieurs états à la
fois vous avez l'image habituelle qu'on
donne c'est celle du chercheur dinger le
shaq est à la fois mort et vivant pour
un électron qui tourne autour d'un
proton dans un atome ça se passe
exactement comme ça l'électron il est
dans toutes les positions de son orbite
à la fois il est partout à la fois sur
son orbite
donc quelque chose de très différent de
ceux dont on a l'habitude nous au niveau
macroscopique à la mécanique quantique
ça peut vous paraître bizarre mais il
faut savoir que ça marche très très bien
déjà c'est ce qui est à la base de toute
notre compréhension actuelle de la
physique des particules et c'est pas
seulement dans les accélérateurs puisque
la mécanique quantique c'est ce qui
aussi nous permet de comprendre comment
marche des semi conducteurs est donc de
faire des transistors des
microprocesseurs et donc sans mécanique
quantique
vous seriez peut-être pas en train de
regarder cette vidéo alors tout ça c'est
très bien mais assez vite
les physiciens sont rendus compte que la
mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale c'était deux théories
totalement incompatibles ça
un peu en relativité générale tout est
continue tout les choses sont dans un
état bien déterminé en mécanique
quantique
les choses sont discontinue les objets
sont dans plusieurs états à la fois donc
ces deux théories sont fondamentalement
incompatible
et vous savez les physiciens il aime
bien et c'est d'unifier les choses s'il
pouvait avoir une seule théorie qui
englobe les deux ça les arrangerait bien
et donc c'est cette hypothétique théorie
qui engloberait les deux qu'on appelle
un peu pompeusement la théorie du tout
alors là vous allez me dire qu'est ce
qu'on s'en fiche d'avoir une théorie du
tout je vous ai dit la mécanique
quantique c'est pour les objets et
microscopiques et la relativité générale
c'est pour les objets très lourd en
général les objets très lourd ils sont
pâles microscopiques et les objets
microscopiques sont pas très lourd alors
en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai on
connaît au moins deux cas où on aurait
bien besoin d'une théorie qui regroupe
mécanique quantique et relativité
générale
le premier c'est pour comprendre ce qui
se passe au centre des trous noirs
vous savez un trou noir ça ne fait que
accumulé de la matière et toute cette
matière elle tombe au centre du trou
noir est donc au centre du trou noir on
a énormément de matière qui se
concentrent dans un très petit volume
pour comprendre ce qui se passe vraiment
au centre d'un trou noir il faut qu'on
ait une théorie qui permettent de faire
à la fois de la relativité générale et
de la mécanique quantique
il faut qu'on ait une théorie du tout
l'autre cas c'est celui des premiers
instants du big bang
en fait dans les premiers instants du
big bang l'univers est dans un état très
très contracté alors il était très lourd
mais il était tellement contracté que
pour comprendre vraiment ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là il faut qu'on ait
une théorie du coup et c'est très
important parce que vous savez on dit
souvent
l'univers est né il ya 13 8 milliards da
en fait
en fait c'est pas vrai en fait on n'en
sait rien si on veut vraiment comprendre
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là il
faut qu'on ait une théorie qui
permettent de faire de la relativité
générale et de la mécanique quantique en
même temps alors qu'est ce qu'a fait aux
kings là dedans en fait
hocking a été le premier dans les années
70 à réussir à mélanger un tout petit
peu la mécanique quantique et la
relativité générale en fait plus
précisément où qu'ils ne travaillaient
sur la physique des trous noirs et il a
montré que si on mettait un peu de
mécanique quantique dans les trous noirs
on trouvait que les trous noirs et
mettait un rayonnement on avait
l'habitude de dire un trou noir c'est
quelque chose qui
peut avaler des choses ça peut rien et m
en fait où king montre que non si on
prend en compte la mécanique quantique
l'image change et les trous noirs
émettent un rayonnement
ce rayonnement c'est de l'énergie et
donc si le trou noir aimé de l'énergie
samas diminue et donc les trous noirs
peuvent maigrir et peuvent même
disparaître complètement
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'évaporation des
trous noirs et donc ça ça a été une
petite révolution puisque pour la
première fois quelqu'un arrivait à
mélanger un petit peu de la mécanique
quantique dans la relativité générale et
en plus en faisant ça du coup ça
modifier complètement l'image qu'on
avait des trous noirs et donc c'est ça
qui reste la grande trouvaille de
hawking sa grande découverte
scientifique est d'ailleurs son nom est
resté attaché à ça puisque ce
rayonnement des trous noirs on l'appelle
le rayonnement de hawking alors
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on en ait dans
la recherche d'une théorie du tout ben
en fait on ne naît pas forcément
beaucoup plus loin que là où on en était
à l'époque de hawking la tentative la
plus aboutie aujourd'hui en tout cas
celles qui bénéficient du plus de
chercheurs et aussi du plus de publicité
elle s'appelle la théorie des cordes
la théorie des cordes son idée c'est de
reprendre un peu les choses à zéro et
dire finalement le monde n'est pas fait
de particules mais il est fait de petits
objets ni dimensionnelle qui sont des
petites cordes et qui comme les
particules peuvent se balader interagir
se désintégrer fusionner et c'est la
théorie des cordes elle permet de
résoudre un certain nombre de problèmes
qu'on avait quand on a essayé de
mélanger un peu naïvement la relativité
générale est la mécanique quantique
il ya juste un prix à payer c'est que la
théorie des cordes elle marche que andy
dimensions vous pouvez pas faire de
théorie des cordes en quatre dimensions
ou en 18 dimension ses dimensions
obligatoire une dimension de temps neuf
dimensions des espaces ça c'est quand
même un problème parce que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire aujourd'hui des
dimensions de l'espace on en a vu que
trois donc il faut expliquer où sont les
six autres alors aujourd'hui la théorie
des cordes celle approche la plus
développée mais elle est encore loin de
pouvoir prétendre à être la théorie du
tout et puis il faut savoir qu'il ya pas
que la théorie des cordes dans la vie il
ya d'autres approches et notamment ces
vingt dernières années il ya une
nouvelle approche qui s'est développée
qui s'appelle la gravité quantique à
boucles alors faut pas vous laisser
tromper par le terme de boucle les
boucles de la gravité quantique à
boucles ont à peu près rien à voir avec
les cordes de la théorie des cordes et
c'est une approche très intéressante
parce que notamment
elle fonctionne en quatre dimensions
c'est à dire une dimension de temps et 3
dimanche
son espace et en particulier les
physiciens qui travaillent sur le sujet
ont regardé comment on pouvait
comprendre les premiers instants du big
bang en utilisant cette théorie est ce
qu'ils ont vu c'est que il était
possible que notre univers ne soit en
fait pas né il ya 13 8 milliards
d'années mais soit le résultat du rebond
d'un univers précédent donc il faut
s'imaginer un univers précédent qui se
serait effondré sur lui même et qui
juste avant d'atteindre une taille
ponctuelles en fait auraient rebondi et
aurait donné notre univers alors fausse
ou dix ans cette approche de la gravité
quantique à boucles
j'ai un petit faible pour elle parce que
c'était mon sujet de recherche et
quelques années je vous promets un jour
je vous ferai une vidéo spécifique sur
la gravité quantique abl merci d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous
a plu sachez que vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne vous pouvez aussi me
retrouver sur mon blog sciences
étonnante ainsi que sur facebook et sur
twitter
à bientôt